wouldn't it be sad
if
these future entities which were the
main intelligent Universe
um had no self-awareness so there was
nothing which could appreciate the
Wonder and mystery of the universe
and the beauty of the universe in the
way that we do
um and and so it does perhaps affect
one's perspective of whether
you welcome or deplore this possible
future scenario depending on whether you
think the the future post-human entities
are conscious and have an aesthetic
sense or whether they're just zombies
and of course you have to be humble
to realize that self-awareness may not
be the highest form of being
that humans have a very strong ego and a
very strong sense of identity like
personal identity connected to this
particular brain yeah yeah uh it's not
so obvious to me that that is somehow
the
the highest achievement
of a life form
that may be this kind of think something
Collective would be it's possible that
uh well I think from an alien
perspective when you look at Earth
it's not so obvious to me that
individual humans are the atoms of
intelligence it could be the entire
organism together the collective
intelligence and so we humans think of
ourselves as individuals we dress up we
Wear Ties and suits and we'll give each
other prizes but in reality
the intelligence the things we create
that are beautiful emerges from our
interaction with each other and that may
be where the intelligence is ideas
jumping from one person to another over
Generations yes but we have experiences
where we can appreciate Beauty and
wonder and all that and uh a zombie may
not have those experiences
yeah or it may have a very different but
you have a very black and white harsh
description of zot like a philosophical
zombie zombie that could be just a very
different way to experience